[Applaus]
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
frau bundeskanzlerin sehr geehrte damen
und herren dieser haushaltsentwurf ist
ein historisches dokument ein dokument
der unverantwortlichen sorglosigkeit
inmitten einer krise die unsere freiheit
die grundlagen des demokratischen
zusammenhalt und das fundament unseres
wohlstandes und wirtschaftlichen erfolgs
und damit auch unseres sozialstaats
zutiefst erschütterte sie aber klammern
sich stur an ihre ideologie politischen
irrtümer euro-rettung eu superstaat
einwanderung ohne grenzen energiewende
auto wende elektroauto planwirtschaft
die in all den jahren nie funktioniert
haben mit denen sie bereits milliarden
an wert vernichtet haben und
unermesslichen schaden angerichtet haben
die korona krise hat sie nicht zur
besinnung gebracht im gegenteil sie
benutzen die krise als vorwand und
ermächtigung um den zug nur umso
schneller über ihre falsch gestellten
weiche zu jagen und dafür gehen sie mit
vollen händen und ohne hemmungen
steuergelder und aus dem nichts
geschäfte schulden geld aus für das die
bürger dieses landes enteignet und noch
in generationen werden gerade stehen
müssen und mit den fehlleistungen der
mitglieder dieser regierung könnte man
inzwischen eine ganze bibliothek film
ein finanzminister und vizekanzler der
eine verfassungswidrige neuverschuldung
trotz hoher rücklagen plant und die
steuer noch weiter erhöhen will
ein blasser und kaum wahrnehmbare
außenminister der islamisten hofiert
sogar in seinem haus beschäftigt und im
un-sicherheitsrat immer wieder gegen
israel stimmen lässt
ein bundesinnenminister der sich
schneller dreht als sein schatten und
der vom zeitweiligen kritiker zum
willigen vollstrecker der willkommens
politik der offenen grill
geworden ist eine
verteidigungsministerin die sich lieber
um politische säuberung und geänderte
dienstgrade kümmert als um den desolaten
ausrüstungsstand und die
einsatzfähigkeit unserer bundeswehr
eine justizministerin die auf kriegsfuß
mit der verfassung steht und die
internetzensur gesetze ihres
amtsvorgängers noch auf die spitze
treiben will
obwohl sie klar verfassungswidrig sind
und über allem thront eine kanzlerin die
in 15 viel zu lang regierungsjahren den
rechtsbruch zum politischen prinzip
gemacht und unser land in europa
zunehmend isoliert hat das verdikt dass
ein britischer politologe vor fünf
jahren über ihre migrationspolitik
gefällt hat deutschland benehme sich wie
ein gefühls geleiteter hippie staat gilt
inzwischen für alle wesentlichen
politikfeldern und darüber kann man nur
den kopf schütteln über eine regierung
die in ihrer hyper moralischen
selbstgerechtigkeit blind die feder von
2015 wiederholt sich mit falschen
willkommens signalen und
sozialleistungen für jedermann zum
magneten für illegale einwanderung macht
die folgen ihrer verantwortungslosen
grenzenlosen asylpolitik tragen die
bürger in form von gestiegener
unsicherheit und kriminalität 95.400
schwere straftaten durch zuwanderer
verzeichnet ein aktuelles bka lagebild
für 2009 10
das sind über 260 gewaltverbrechen durch
zuwanderer pro tag
wir sind auch schon lange kein reiches
land mehr beim medien vermögen der
privathaushalte bei der
wohneigentumsquote und beim rentenniveau
liegen die deutschen im eu-vergleich
weit abgeschlagen auf den hinteren
plätzen in den krisenstaaten des südens
an die wir jahr für jahr milliarden
trans
das richten sind die bürger im schnitt
reicher und die rentner besser versorgt
teilweise um ein vielfaches
spitzenplätze belegt deutschland dagegen
bei steuern abgaben und strompreisen bei
der aufnahme von asylbewerbern aus aller
herren länder und bei der quote der von
armut bedrohten kinder und älteren
menschen
auch das ist ein ergebnis ihrer politik
und dass sie nicht die kennzahlen eines
reichen landes das sind die zahlen aus
einem land dem der absturz droht
um es ganz klar zu sagen wir haben kein
geld zu verschenken so lange ein teil
unserer rentner in mülltonnen nach
pfandflaschen sucht und so über die
runden zu kommen
trotzdem verwenden sie steuergeld und
volksvermögen der deutschen für die
rettung des euro sind die errichtung
eines völlig undemokratischen eu super
staates die offenen forderungen aus den
tage zwei seiten haben die
millionengrenze überschritten dass es
exportiert das volksvermögen das nur
noch auf dem papier steht aber faktisch
uneinbringlich ist von den unzähligen
milliardenschweren rettungsprogramme
ganzen schreiben die von ihnen
ausgerufene energiewende ist ebenfalls
die nächste europäische lachnummer
wer kommt auf die idee aus kohle
verstromung und kernkraft gleichzeitig
auszusteigen und sich dafür auch noch zu
feiern
klar grüne ökos und die tiefen er grünte
union und der rest europa wird ihn in
diese sackgasse nicht folgen
wind und sonnenstrom sind nicht
grundlastfähig und der flächenbedarf für
die erzeugung derselben leistung ist
gegenüber kohlekraft und kernkraft
mindestens um den faktor 1000 höher auf
gut deutsch das kann überhaupt gar nicht
funktionieren und unsere nachbarn in den
niederlanden
planen derweil für eine co2 arme zukunft
zehn neue kernkraftwerke auch hier gilt
sie sind die geisterfahrer auch nicht
die anderen die alle in die
entgegengesetzte richtung fahren und sie
setzen planwirtschaft und staatliche
lenkung an die stelle von freiheit
wettbewerb und innovationskraft der
bundeswirtschaftsminister der kühne
pläne vorlegt um die wirtschaft um zu
bauen sollte so ehrlich sein und endlich
seine ludwig erhard büßte in seinem büro
durch eine karl-marx-stadt ersetzen
[Applaus]
kein staat und erst recht keine eu kann
am tisch planen welche energieträger
welcher antrieb uns ins nächste
jahrhundert bringt überlassen sie die
antwort darauf bitte der
innovationskraft unserer unternehmen den
konsumenten und den freien wettbewerb
die klimaschutzpläne und die permanente
absurde verschärfung der eu grenzwerte
werden der deutschen automobilindustrie
den todesstoß versetzen
statt sich zu widersetzen agieren sie
als williger vollstrecker so wie er soll
der die neuzulassung von
verbrennungsmotoren untersagen will
dieser krieg gegen die autoindustrie ist
ein feldzug gegen gut bezahlte
produktive arbeitsplätze gegen den
wohlstand und gegen die steuerzahler die
den sozialstaat derzeit noch finanzieren
dahinter 15.000 jobs weg zf
friedrichshafen weitere 15.000
continental 13.000 mrm 9000 bmw 6000
schaeffler 4500 und das ist nur die
spitze des eisberges
daran hängen hunderttausende schicksale
familien die ihre lebensgrundlage
verlieren hart erarbeitete
mittelständische existenzen die in den
abgrund gerissen werden und es sind die
leistungsträger es sind die
leistungsträger die dieses land am
laufen halten und denen sie den boden
unter den füßen wegziehen und diesen
niedergang können sie nicht auf die
korona krise schien ihre überzogenen
maßnahmen machen aus der korona krise
die schwerste rezession in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland hunderttausende insolvenzen
drohen in diesem herbst und winter in
gastronomie und handel tourismus und
veranstaltungswirtschaft im mittelstand
und dienstleistungsgewerbe dank ihrer
corona politik sind immer mehr menschen
und wirtschaftszweige von staatlichen
zuwendungen abhängig
und das ist der sichere weg in den
sozialismus und in not kommen sie
herunter von diesem irrweg hören sie auf
panik zu schüren und einen
wirtschaftszweig nach dem anderen mit
willkürlichen und überzogenen auflagen
und einschränkungen zu strangulieren
behandeln sie die bürger dieses landes
richtige ungünstige kinder bei denen sie
nach belieben die zügel anziehen oder
brachial durchgreifen
geben sie freiheit und
eigenverantwortung den bürgern die der
erste priorität staatswirtschaft und
sozialismus funktionieren nämlich nicht
und werden nie funktionieren der öko
sozialismus licht der klima sozialismus
nicht und der korona sozialismus auch
nicht gedanken
[Applaus]